the people who control the institutions
got high on the supply of leftism
they were being fed algorithmic junk
that would generate more clicks and more
traffic for these rage bait blogs
and so they started to go insane
believing insane things
let me tell you guys something i've long
ex i've i've often explained how the
algorithmic psychosis took hold in
america
for those that are not familiar i'm
going to explain it for those that are
familiar please bear with me as i
explain to those who are not familiar
in the late 2000s facebook and youtube
and twitter and whatever else we're
trying to figure out algorithms
not so much twitter twitter didn't go
algorithmic for a while they're trying
to figure out
how to get the most amount of engagement
on posts
so they created algorithms regular
people
ben would see a post and it would say i
like chocolate chip cookies
and they would interact with it and then
facebook would be like
people seem to like chocolate chip
cookies show them more posts about
cookies
but then one day someone posts a video
of a black man being beaten by police
and all of a sudden a million shares 300
million views
and the facebook algorithm without any
disdain for what the video was said
this is what people want to see no i
don't think people wanted to see that i
think they were mad about it and want
people to know because they wanted
justice
well the algorithm then started feeding
more of these videos but more
importantly
humans figured it out humans figured out
i get way more views
when i post these videos so the ragebate
blog started posting more and more and
more of this in fact at one point there
was a website dedicated to nothing but
police brutality that was in the top
global 500 websites
all they did was post police brutality
videos then
something more magical happened the
discovery of intersectional feminism
wait a minute if we combine racism and
sexism
we don't just get x views or y views and
we don't get x plus y
we get x y views an exponential increase
by combining the keywords thus we saw
the rise of intersectionality
which was was this idea which is rooted
in it stems from critical race theory
that a black woman experiences a unique
kind of sexism and racism that a black
man and a white woman would not
experience creating an
all-new interpretation of racism
what ends up happening is you have all
of these companies producing rage bait
to the to the great to grady every
article
is police brutality non-stop mike.com
started as my understanding is a ron
paul libertarian website no way did mike
start off as ron paul
that's that's why there was an
investigation i read about so correct me
if i'm wrong everybody but
it started off by just being like what
was the internet what was big on the
internet back then
ron paul john paul he was number one on
reddit i mean that's where i first heard
about bitcoin was a ron paul event but
then something happened
they realized that anger was
was the number one with the emotion that
caused the highest amount of shares
so then instead of being about ron paul
it became about police brutality now you
gotta understand too the ron paul crowd
overlapped
with the police brutality crowd because
libertarians
didn't like seeing people be beaten by
cops and they liked ron paul too
but the priest brutality people found
that enraging people with
intersectionality
was worth more and eventually it leaves
the ron paul people behind who are
probably to be completely honest more
rational in their thinking and they were
looking for information they were
finding it they're getting away from the
mainstream
which brings me to the current state of
our generational
algorithmic psychosis someone who is 10
years old
in 2008 goes on facebook maybe for the
first time i know they're not supposed
to because she's supposed to be 13.
but they're 10. and what do they see
nothing but police brutality videos
every video in their feed is a cop
beating a black man
five years goes by a third of their life
is
inundated with non-stop posts of police
beating black men now does that mean
that
more and more cops are doing this no not
at all it's just that
when you have how many how many million
300 something million interactions with
cops per year
a handful of them are going to get
really really bad some may be taken out
of context
now it's it's ten years later we're
talking 2018
and these kids are now 20 years old half
of their lives
they have seen nothing but the police
brutality videos and racism and sexism
now it's 2021.
now they're all in their in their early
to mid 20s these young people
most of their lives inundated with
algorithmic
psychosis is it true that police
sometimes will beat a person
unjustly it is does does sometimes mean
a lot
it actually doesn't it's a lot relative
okay sure it is
but out of hundreds of millions of
interactions with police
a tiny tiny fraction i think the wall
street journal said 19
unarmed black men were killed by police
that's a problem
each and every one of those deaths is
bad but when you play those videos on
loop for a decade
people's worldview these kids they grew
up in a world
where the only thing they ever saw were
these videos played on repeat
sometimes from different angles i mean
the internet is like raising kids now
like i feel like i was raised by the
internet and i mean i had a great family
and all that but a lot of people they
don't even have a great family and
they're raised by the internet but these
kids grow up in a world that doesn't
exist
yeah so i remember i i noticed this from
time to time you go on reddit
and i'll see the same police brutality
video from like 2014
and it pops up once a week because it
gets karma because if someone says i
want to get internet points they put it
they post it and they know people are
going to upvote it and they don't know
or they don't care
that it's really old that 10 year old
kid sees that video
every week and then they forget they see
it a month later and then they engage
and these these videos are constantly
recycled in this way
it's it's it's algorithmic psychosis
that is warping the minds of people who
live in the internet who are growing up
with it
the other thing that is causing the the
chaos is what i call the scaling problem
and it's basically if you have a hundred
police officers
and one of them is a dick who uh and a
psychopath
who beats somebody that's one percent
most people are going to be like arrest
that guy
problem solved it's just one guy if you
have a hundred
million police officers you've now got a
million cops going around doing all this
stuff that's a very very serious problem
but it's the same percentage now it's
not nearly that high in terms of bad
police officers we do have problems with
cops don't get me wrong
in terms of like enforcing unjust laws
or seizing people's guns and things like
that and violating the constitution
and violating people's free speech i've
seen it the cops
who sprayed those girls uh the women at
occupy wall street for no reason just
walked up tony bologna and he sprayed
her that's wrong
but when you look at the actual ratio
these people who grow up in the paranoid
delusional world of
of rage bait algorithms and their whole
lives have been inundated with this
they live in this world that's
completely inverted the 0.001 percent of
cops who are actually doing these things
become the 99.99 of cops because they've
never seen other interactions
now they're going into politics now
they're voting so if you
think everything is going to stop what
people need to understand is it's not
about you
it's about the kids from 10 years ago
and where they are now it's about the
kids who are 15 years old right now
what they've been raised on and who they
will vote for in the next three years
which could be crazy crackpot
far left cult member who microwaves
their underwear and is using a curling
iron
to make pancakes because that's what
they see on the internet could be kanye
west
i believe that's not so bad i believe i
love kanye so much i mean those sunday
services are amazing
i mean that's why i want to get into
politics actually i feel like kanye was
one of the biggest motivators
um because just just seeing someone you
know like in the song reborn
uh and all that with kid cudi it was it
was just so beautiful
you know i want all the smoke i want all
the pain i want all the blame
what an awesome thing engulfed in shame
and uh
and that's that's what made me want to
because i've i've been like what got me
into bitcoin was was ron paul and all
that and that whole world and meaning
some guy had a
had a bitcoin it was actually adam
kokesh it was actually an atom called
cash event and what do you want
people i forgot the i mean it was around
when bitcoin had come out recently
and my older brother brought me to an
adam koch event and
he uh uh he uh got arrested the
jefferson memorial for dancing
and all that do you remember that i
vaguely remember that yeah and then my
brother uh we flew in
and uh we went to go protest that um
and then yeah so it was like a footloose
like protest and then some guy had this
orange
uh bitcoin shirt on or had an orange b
and it looked like a dollar sign like
what's that and he's like it's bitcoin
man it's going to end wall street bro
and he you know ran off
you know what i love about that started
at all you know i love about bitcoin
what
the people who endorse it early on had
no idea what it was
at all and the reason i didn't buy is
because me and my friends
more so knew what it was now uh so my
story is that back in 2011
bitcoin was at 70 cents and i look over
to my friend i'm in l.a at hackerspace
70 cents per bitcoin and i'm like i was
like hey
i was like i got five grand in savings
should i just buy
all this bit like put it all in bitcoin
because i'm not gonna touch the money
you know what i mean
it's gonna it's just my savings in my
bank account and he goes dude
like first of all how do you even buy
this stuff and the second of all it's
probably a scam like
somebody makes this and they tell you
it's valuable and sure
it's like you know winners get bitcoin
but he's like what can you really do
you're going to buy it and then a month
it's going to be a fad and then you're
going gonna lose everything
and i was like that's that that's that's
a good point i won't buy well i'm
familiar with
the people calling product scams when
they're not so i remember seeing it and
thinking like okay so now
my currency's gonna be i gotta write a
string of numbers on on letters on paper
if my paper gets lost or burned it's
gone forever and if i lose access to
electricity i can't i don't have my
money so i didn't get into it but what
was your
impetus to get into it well so actually
yeah do you want to tell us what year
and how you
yeah i got into it 2011 um as well so
i had about a my grandmother who was
very old and uh
and she gave gave me a thousand dollars
and she's like
you know eric use this for your
scholarship you know one day go to
school
and uh i'm gonna buy fake internet money
and that's what i did
so that's what i ended up doing um so i
bought that
uh my yeah my my brother taught me how
to like get that out and actually
playing bitcoin was easier back in the
day because
it was like you could just pay some guy
over paypal
you know and then and get bitcoin sent
to your wall just i mean you had bitcoin
faucets back in the day which is where
they would give away free bitcoin i got
0.15 bitcoin from that faucet
wow yeah bitcoin.org right yeah that
computer got destroyed though oh my god
so i i i
probably i don't even know how many
bitcoin around the computer the computer
i had back in the hackerspace because i
didn't
i didn't put my savings into it but i
still did get some bitcoin
it was worthless i was like whatever
it's like i had like a dollar
yeah that happened that happened to my
friend he he american airlines lost his
bag
and uh and that had about 500 bitcoin
yeah i know
where did you store it in the beginning
uh back in the day and not definitely
not now but i just store it on my laptop
like you download like the bitcoin.org
lat you know
yeah desktop wallet and that's what you
did i'll pack a socks if anybody
remembers that
and yeah i mean i was a weird kid i mean
some kids had video games some kid at
sports mine was bitcoin i just spent
every day
and i ended up actually i dropped out of
high school because i had some bitcoin
money then
moved moved my butt to uh to palo alto
silicon valley
and just like you know tried to do a
business and all that and that ended up
going well
but um eventually sold that company put
it all back into bitcoin but
bitcoin to me i mean when i first got
into it i i actually did think it was
going to be big but it was kind of in
the way you like you hope for world
peace
like it's like why don't you hope for it
but you don't know what happened there's
a funny meme
where it's like some some it's like a
guy who's like wearing a nice polo and
glasses
and he's like bitcoin seems interesting
but i'm not entirely sure that people
will build confidence in this
decentralized network
but i'll look into it and the next guy
is like fat with like a beard and flies
and
he's like i want to buy drugs on the
internet and it's like that guy's a
millionaire
now yeah because he was just like some
scumbag was like i don't care
did you uh pre-install uh wallets
or on the freedom phone wallets there's
a crypto wild on the phone what's it
called
uh it's uh it's called metal pay
actually so that's can you
do you have the phone yes you want to do
you want to pull it out i have to pull
it out do you want to pull out
your phone so we won't use the pronoun i
know i don't want to pull it out but
that's another thing
like everyone told me when i got into
bitcoin you know and they all they were
all like yeah bro that's a scam bro
get out of here someone took your money
on the internet some guy named bitcoin
took your money and
you know and that's how it happened and
then i i got into an argument with some
handcap guy
and i was like it was funny because i
was like talking about
this is this is like probably 2012 or
13. i was like so bitcoin was still
relatively cheap back then
and i was talking about my concerns and
he didn't know anything
at all and he's probably like worth
hundreds of millions of dollars right
now
and i'm like i wish i was dumb you know
what i mean and just like oh cool
bitcoin and cap whoo anarchy
and then i just bought a bunch not
thinking about it but i was like hmm
there are some very interesting problems
with this
we saw some of the hard forks not the
hard farts the hard forks the the
bitcoin cash and there were the no no
the accidental ones oh
do you remember when uh i think this in
2013 bitcoin forked
on accident oh yeah and then they had to
like do an emergency like no no that's
not the real thing anymore and like
switch to this node
and so i was like but you know the
mistake i made back then was
it was it it was an investing in the one
thing the end caps understood
was that it was a decentralized
non-copyable asset
that was difficult to locate and that's
all that really mattered
and so there i was in cap back when i
was you know 12. but there's that
there's two things there's that and that
in and of itself was like we don't care
what the value of the bitcoin is
i can have this bitcoin and trade it and
it's easy the other thing was back in
the day
it was actually a very uh interesting
way to transfer funds
very quickly internationally not because
you cared about the value of bitcoin put
it this way
i need to give you let's say i need to
give you a dollar and i
like you're you're a thousand miles away
so i can't hand you the dollar
so what i do is i go on i send you a
dollars worth of bitcoin and then you
immediately sell it
for a dollar so i just transfer the
dollar instantly no
no neither of us are holding bitcoin i
go to the site i say buy bitcoin
send and then you go accept bitcoin sell
the dollar transferred
like that that was an early on that was
very very early in bitcoin's history
when i was like now i started to
understand why this is such a powerful
tool
because it basically cuts out a lot of
the financial infrastructure for
transferring funds very quickly
it didn't matter what the price of a
bitcoin was because if someone could
transfer value instantly
then there would be more demand for
buying than selling
and so that's when i was like okay i'll
get some bitcoin and start taking more
seriously and since then i have
i mean that yeah i mean the end caps
back in the day i mean i was really into
that and i
still still a part of me um and uh uh
but i mean that was that whole world was
just you know
a bunch of i mean that's that's how all
great things get started is people that
are
are a little different and all that and
so but
how did you uh you so you bought in 2011
you bought all these bitcoin
and then when did you become a
millionaire uh yeah so uh i became a
millionaire at 18 so i was like 12 back
then
so again that was wait you bought
bitcoin when you were 12. yeah i bought
bike when i was 12.
and uh again it was easier back in the
day because uh you know uh
although i ended up having to do it
later but all the kyc stuff you know you
could just like yeah paypal some guy on
local bitcoins
and uh so that's what i did and um
yeah i mean i was 12 years old and i
just spent every day i was like mowing
lawns just to try to get more money to
put into it
really yeah see that's that's that
because a lot of people say
like when i tell that story about having
the five grand in savings and wanting to
buy bitcoin
everyone responds with you would have
sold it 20 bucks and i'm like you're
correct
if if i put 500 bitcoin and hit 20 i'd
be like
and i'd sell right away i'd be like just
get up because i didn't know i
wasn't smart enough i guess i didn't
have the vision i didn't see it i think
to me it was just my whole identity was
wrapped up in bitcoin because it's like
what are you going to do as a 14 year
old
you know with with this money when it
went up and then that and then
again it was just like i i was just
obsessed with bitcoin and it was my
identity and it just inspired me of
uh to do so many other things um but
yeah i came millionaire at uh
18 i'm 22 now i'm an old man
um did that and then yeah a bunch of
articles came out you know youngest
bitcoin millionaire
um which was nice but you know it's
ultimately was you know
cool i guess you didn't buy doge i did
buy some doji leon
i did cash out doge early though that
was that was my stay i i now have some
coin in
in uh in doge um and all that but uh uh
but yeah i mean i was i was on bitcoin i
mean i remember i made like 300 bucks on
dogecoin like back in the day and i was
like well this is as far as it's going
to go because dogecoin is one of those
coins that has lasted for such a long
time
i mean they did the whole nascar thing
early on and then after that faded i was
like wow maybe doj i love how in the
early days of bitcoin
there was like thousands of alt coins
we'll call them alt coins
and they were just like clones of
bitcoin with different names
and then people would be like this is
the one that's gonna beat bitcoin and
i'm like it's nothing it's all the same
thing it's like you just cloned the code
and then
made it and then sold it and people made
money doing it it was it was crazy
because
even if it was almost worthless you
could make like a million coins go on
some
some uh trading uh website and people
would be like
i'll give you bitcoin for it it was so
scammy in there i know and it still is
yeah yeah i mean litecoin was one of
those things i mean
seeing like coin like ethereum's kind of
the new like coin but i remember like
coin was just you would always
it would whenever bitcoin went up like
litecoin was always that number two
and they would say bitcoin is gold
litecoin is silver yeah exactly exactly
i mean it was literally the logos and it
was
it was uh that was just such a crazy
beautiful time
and uh and wild wild west of the
internet it was the wild wild west on
the internet and
uh and then again i mean i remember
there was this thing called world of
text
and it was like when chrome first came
out and you had like a
webgl i think it was called and it was
uh and and it basically was this whole
just giant
text page where you could just write
anything and be yourself and all that
and that was what was beautiful and and
you know and again i just feel like uh
not to tie it into today but i mean just
it's just they're taking away
the ability to be yourself and people
use the terms like free speech and
all that and i mean that's that's a the
perfect term for it but what does that
really mean it's the right to have your
own voice the right to be yourself
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you